the idea is to make the the startup
leaving and growing
and if this work at the same time the
impact that you will have in the
environment on in other people will
will grow with the startups
[Music]
matteo buffa thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders how are you today
hi michael thank you so much for
inviting me i'm very very good
what about you i'm very i'm fantastic
thank you so you're talking from dubai
right now right
yes yes i'm right now in dubai marina
yes where
it's it's a bit unusual to see people in
dubai with uh
with this kind of clothes but it's uh
it's getting quite cold
amazing well the last time that we that
we actually met was in the dubai marina
we had a great coffee there and i got to
learn all about your
your incredible adventures within the
sustainability space and with startups
but your your history goes back actually
to switzerland right
you're from switzerland you were in the
financial sector you also served in the
army there
and then you made your way to dubai and
now you're working with startups on
sustainability and environment so mattel
tell me a little bit about your life and
and a little bit of of
what led you to this realization that
what you're truly passionate about
is working on sustainable on companies
that are working on sustainability yes
for sure
you know in switzerland we are kind of
famous for chocolate
knives and cheese and cows and banks
so my family they are
bankers since almost 100 years in
switzerland and
my future was destinated to be in the
same field of finance and banking
i started working at the age of 15 years
old in switzerland is something quite
normal because it's an apprenticeship
system where you have
a third of work a third of a school and
a third of a bank academy
so i had these three years as an
apprenticeship
in this bank in lugano
and after i got employed by the the same
bank
and i i work for for the bank for 10
years
in the meantime i did a course a
marketing master
during the weekend and during the the
weekends um
and um yeah because that was my passion
but of course
working 100 i didn't really had the time
to go
to a new full university um after that i
did two years in the swiss army
and this helped me a lot to learn about
the leadership and
command and how dynamics in the real
work
uh function same as in in the bank
and um after you know i i was happy i
was in a very safe uh
environment and a safe job a good salary
but i was not really satisfied about
what was uh what i was doing
uh what i was making for for for for
myself and for other people in
around the world so i decided to go
abroad
to new york because i didn't
had any english background so i started
in in new york
uh and after that i decided to to move
to dubai
as it was shown as a land of opportunity
i opened my first company that was
recycling uh plastic material
i partially sold my company and now my
job is to
reinvest part of my private capital into
startups
that are they are having a social and
environmental
uh impact and at the same time i was
able to
be part of the swiss chamber of commerce
and i became now the the president of
the swiss business council abu dhabi um
yeah the swiss business council in abu
dhabi i love it
so you know even before we get to to
recycling and the environmental
sustainability and all of that stuff i
talked to a little bit about the swiss
and the the work that you're doing
connecting switzerland and the united
arab emirates
through the swiss council so what are
you actually doing there why do you
spend so much time with that
yeah you know this is a a non-profit
organization it's
not supported by the the swiss
government we live
thanks to our members that can be social
members so individual or as mid small
medium or large
companies what we do basically we
connect
the swiss community from switzerland to
come into the uae to open businesses
or uae companies or individuals to go uh
to switzerland so we
we we're kind of up connecting dots
between these two
two countries so and so
tell me a little bit about what are you
doing particularly with the members
what is their involvement what do you
expect from them what do they gain out
of it
and how does this whole thing work yeah
so
um becoming a member it's quite easy the
only requirement is to have a swiss link
so swiss national or swiss-based company
and what we do we we help for example
swiss technology to approach the uae
market
and opening branches of their businesses
um
we have three major pillar uh in the in
the swiss council one is the
environmental group
one is the financial group and the other
one uh is the health group
uh recently uh it's very interesting
that we open
the agritech group um that
everything related to vertical farming
or smart farming
um okay i see so so now going back a
little bit to this environmental and
sustainability
what tell me first of all a bit more
about the company that you've that you
started
what led you to even go that route
yeah um as i said as a banker i was um
partially happy uh but i wanted to let a
positive footprint
impact uh for the next generation i
realized that the uae is an amazing
country full of opportunity
but there was a gap in the system in
when it comes to recycling and
and sustainability so was a fertile and
virgin
uh field where entering was quite
uh easy um and where the number of
people involved is not
to to too many you know it's a it's an
undiscovered
was an undiscovered field right i think
the perfect move
and so you discover that there's this
whole gap in the market
and there's a great alignment with your
own personal interest with the impact
that you can make on others and you
partially sell the
this company of yours and you're taking
part of the proceeds to now go and
invest in other
um sustainability companies give me a
little bit of taste as to what types of
companies are involved with and
and why you're involved specifically
with them so yeah the first one
uh was basically taking uh big big
advertising posters
uh the billboards that you can easily
see around shakeside road
this is a pvc material that is very
thick and after the
marketing and advertising campaign is
supposed to be destroyed because you
cannot reuse it
so my company used to take down this
advertising cut it clean it and create
unique objects so basically we'll have a
backpack that is the
unique backpack in the world to
represent a small part of this
huge billboard um this had a very
interesting
uh traction because it's a b2b concept
so we don't
we didn't sell through the final
consumer but directly to the company
company that we're advertising like
porsche nespresso
mercedes apple uh etc so
what this company did they bought
through us and they were reselling these
these goods or giving away as
a gift to show uh that their marketing
uh
campaign was not ending under under the
sand under the ceo burned
but was just continuing uh traveling
around the world
very very cool and tell me a little bit
about about the flip floppy because that
one particularly caught my
caught my eye yeah i'm i'm helping the
flip-floppy project
in spreading the awareness uh in kenya
so the flip flopping project
built the first uh boat completely built
by plastic trash recovered from from the
ocean and from the
from the landfill um
and it's called the fleet fluffy because
the external side it's all covered
in old flip-flop uh recovered as uh from
from the beaches
and um this is a very interesting uh
non-profit organization
as well supported by united nation and
uh
we were able to to to sail the the boat
from from kenya to zanzibar and now
my role is to try to find other
investors and other partners
so talk to me a little bit about the the
life cycle of a company that
is primarily you know thinking about the
environment and sustainability because
obviously that's a very different
model than than a traditional startup
where your matrix or perhaps
you know your your arr and how much you
know
the margins that you're able to take and
how many customers you're able to
acquire
here there's actually different kpis
right that you would want to measure
in a sustainability company so what what
are some of those kpis and how do you
actually go about
quantifying a success in that regard
yeah we have to consider that in the
past sustainability or sustainable
product were considered
cheap things and things that were not
profitable at all
uh now luckily the the people and the
world uh
there is awareness about it and you can
actually make money out of doing
something great for the people and for
for the environment
so of course the most important thing is
to measure
measure the impact that any of these
startups is doing
and of course seeing the sustainability
not only for the environment but the
financial sustainability the team
sustainability and everything that
builds the startup has to be
in in a perfect balance in terms of
return of investment uh from myself as
an investor
i'm not looking for a short vision i
want to to build a team i want to create
a company that has a long long term
vision
uh for for everybody and can as well
survive in the time during the time
right but but from you know from my
perspective i'm saying you know
the regular um the regular startup scene
that you have a very key
yeah very key matrix that you're able to
compare one startup to another right a
lot of them are
the customer acquisition your cost of
acquisition for customers
your your annual revenue your margins
etc
i'm imagining that in the space that
you're in where every startup has a
different mission
uh that to help in the world in some
regard
you can't really compare it's like
comparing oranges to apples right so how
do you actually go about
talking to a teammate evaluating whether
what they're doing actually makes
an impact given the investment they're
spending
and obviously that's putting aside the
financial returns that you would expect
as an investor
yeah it's something relatively new as i
said so there is not really a secret
behind like in any startup
uh uh me as an angel investor i have
my go first got feeling and see um what
is
the idea behind but as well what is the
team uh in the past i
i had many investments that didn't went
well
because um the idea was good and the
financial
side was good but the team was not good
or
many other components so it's difficult
to
to create a pattern and say this is the
10 20 points that will make a startup
succeed right
the environment change we see now with
this pandemic situation
you cannot really create a string that
determines the success of any startups
all right but but is the success a a
factor of taking a sum of money
spending it and seeing how much you're
helping the world i mean are those
things in the discussion as you're
from your experience with these teams do
they think okay how can we spend
x money to make a wide impact on the
world and that's really the value
proposition of that startup or does it
act like a regular startup
trying to acquire customers and and and
get revenue
the idea is to make the the startup
leaving and growing
and if this work at the same time the
impact that you will have in the
environment on in other people will
will grow with the startups doesn't
really make sense to
to put uh wanting something to have a
short-term vision and
and collecting plastic left and right
and at the end of
one year two years they start stop
startup failed because it's not
financially sustainable so it's
investing in a group on a team in an
idea
that will grow um organically
through the success and at the same time
uh building the the
corporate social responsibility aspect
right because one of the things that
i've been observing
from the sidelines is that you know to
make a real impact you need to
you need to to grow at scale right you
need to have all the incentives aligned
with
among all the different uh stakeholders
and it's not enough
for the nonprofit yet funding from you
know philanthropists
and then have that you know very narrow
impact
through that money but if you're
actually able to to provide a
sustainable business
with a coherent revenue model that it
can sustain and grow itself
and you're socially aware and you're
doing something good for the world
that's really where the impact is
because i'm sure that if one of your
companies then
comes to be a unicorn while its core
mission is still to make the world a
better place whether it's through
recycling
social awareness whatever then that's a
really big deal right mattel
yes now that's correct and i can give
you a very uh very good example on that
uh one of my my startups it's called
telly and what we do we produce the
first
uh vegan shoes entirely made with
plastic
waste so uh we were able through
our two round of investment to to
make hundred thousand shoes in the first
bench uh
what we decided is let's start with a
concept of thousand
five hundred shoes let's see how it goes
let's improve the concept let's see what
is the reaction what is the impact and
how we can
keep the money that we saved aside to
improve
uh the production system the the um the
chain
uh that we that we
we have at the moment so it's not just
collecting morning and stem spending all
of them
i'm more into the concept of tasting the
market testing the idea testing
uh the team and um evolved all together
right now that makes a lot of sense and
and more broadly where are we headed
do we see an increase of companies that
are working on sustainability is there a
decrease how does the market how is the
market responding to this
um for sure the the the number of
companies
increasing by by day or by hours um
as i said in the past you were thinking
sustainability and green
action as a as a good will to to to make
a small change
now uh investor uh
obviously bigger than me they realize
that you can actually
make money out of a good action and a
good product so
um that was a very uh gray
area uh that now it's it's more clear
and
all the research and um all the studies
make uh
our life easier and also the consumer
itself
it's uh it's reacting very positive um
in the past you know if you were buying
up let's use again the shoes
uh that were the shoes on the market and
you will really know who was making it
but
if it was a kid of five years old
stitching
uh your shoes or or or a grown adult
with a
proper infrastructure were to work you
would never know now
technology social media uh journals tv
can
can really help the the small company
that
really make an impact and and the
consumer now
buy this kind of product because they
want to to really see what is behind
right one of the things that i've
actually been observing as well is that
a lot of
vcs traditional vcs that previously
weren't
specifically investing in these types of
markets because you don't really
because i guess the reason is that it's
much harder to see that hockey stick
growth right that exponential growth in
a company that
has a core value which is a
sustainability or helping the world in
one way or another but a lot of these
venture capital funds now have a whole
segment for
impact investing it's a term that i've
been hearing a lot this idea to invest
in companies that are that
have a core value or coordination to
make an impact and so i can definitely
see why
why this is a growing trend and
obviously what we've been seeing
in the past few years not just in the in
the environment but you know socially
and with the world
on itself i think that there's a lot of
things that that we need sustainability
to
uh to improve upon uh but matteo talk to
me a little bit about
your your advice for young entrepreneurs
that are starting their journey
that might be interested in going into
the sustainability space you've made a
radical transition in your life to go
towards sustainability and
and what would you say to some young
entrepreneurs that might not even be
thinking about this as a
as a potential yeah you know
i have to say i have to consider myself
very lucky because i'm coming from a a
good country i'm living now in the uae
this is a very good country as well
uh i had some financial that i was able
to save during the my
my past in in the bank it's not easy
i was privileged and that's the reason
why i'm trying to help
a young entrepreneur in uh with the
small
steps uh financially just to right uh
reach from the idea to a prototype or to
a from
the idea to a first step or as well to
connect
uh already developed uh startups to
bigger investors than me
um resilience it's something that
it's very important important nowadays
means uh being able to adapt to any type
of
um circumstances and situation now again
with this pandemic we saw
many uh company fail but as well many
new opportunities rising so
always keep the eyes open make a lot of
research
uh my big suggestion for young
entrepreneur
is to learn and study about what they
really want to achieve
not because they wake up and they have
an idea and they think is the best idea
in the in the world
make some research before about the
market about
uh if it's something that already exists
and after
start the conversation now that makes a
lot of sense and when you choose
investors to join you on this journey
assuming that right now
you still have to to choose carefully
people that are going to be supportive
of you of your long-term vision right
and not the short-term success that's
something that you repeated quite a few
times
why is that important focusing on the
long-term vision with these types of
companies rather than short-term success
yeah the world is changed i think a
short-term uh
profit uh will disappear very soon uh
in the past as uh was different
technology different approach
uh the market was smaller all around the
world
so believing in something that you can
build
in in a in a long term will always be
the the success and you can as well
implement your strategy
based on a long term and not in a short
term so
i think this is has to be the way
of thinking for for the future
generation i completely agree matteo
thank you so much for taking the time to
join me
in this episode it was really really
wonderful i i love
meeting you back in dubai and and i'm
personally inspired by your
but your passion for sustainability and
transitioning your life to be to put
that at
the forefront obviously you know it's
not at least in
still in 2021 it's not the most
economically uh you know
a economically viable thing to do
there's a lot of other things that are
much sexier with a hockey stick growth
but this is definitely something that
that is literally making the world a
better place and so i i'm imagining that
you sleep
better at night than most people but
mateo thank you for coming and before we
leave i have to ask you for the most
important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
yeah i would say resilience uh
creativity and uh yeah
never give up it's not really a word but
this shows me
uh that even if you fail just uh put
uh put not put your hands in your pocket
but try to
to rise and and learn from your mistake
that's the
the most important thing everybody will
make mistake everybody will fail
multiple times as well i i feel many
times but just
rise as a phoenix and and try to do your
best every day
i love that and i'll just add to that
the motto that you sent me earlier which
is
don't spend to destroy invest to create
which i i completely love that mateo
thank you very very much
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
michael very appreciate
and i hope to see you very soon thank
you